I'm pretty sure the
reason I'm on this earth
is to make people
happy, because that's
what that I'm really good at.
The most I've ever made in
a month was $10 thousand.
My honest first
impression was like how
or these people
falling for this?
I heard it from my sister
in law when I was about 14.
She said that she had
found this great website
and she was making money
just to talk to guys.
I was just like, wow, I
can't wait until I'm 18
and I can do that.
The first time I cam with
someone it'll usually just
be talking, we just talk.
Then I feel a lot
more comfortable.
They enjoy it a lot
more because then they
know who I am a little bit.
It's not just like seeing
a stripper on a pole.
After that, usually they
want me to watch them
they want to be able to
see my private parts.
That's just great for them.
Just whatever they
want, typically.
I mean, within reason.
I'm talking to this
guy, he's been trying
to chat me for a long time.
He sent me $10 just so
I would chat with him.
My boyfriend always
notices whenever
I'm sexy chatting some guys.
You know, like dirty talk,
erotic, cybering, whatever.
Because I have a sexy
look in my eyes and I'm
smirking and smiling
and blushing.
He'll be like, you
quit doing that.
Everyone's different.
Some people only
want to type message.
And some people only want
photos of me in panties.
There's actually a guy that
only likes photos of girls
strapped into a car seat.
And I'm like, okay.
I'll do that.
I actually work a lot.
I put a lot of work
into this and that's
why I get a lot of
results from it.
I always try to be
on, on my phone.
I'm always trying
to be logged on.
In case somebody's having
a bad day, messages me.
I work a lot.
I pretty much work 24/7.
When it comes to having a
kid and everything else,
I work a lot.
I do this because I didn't want
to have to send her to daycare
and go get a job.
I wanted to be
with her every day.
I wanted to be able
to raise her and I
wanted to take that
full responsibility of I
am her mother and
she is my child.
And she's perfect now.
She's great.
I've raised her.
A lot of people in my life
do know that I do this.
Pretty much everyone because I'm
just really open, I don't care.
If anybody's going to
judge me then feel free.
Really I have gained a
lot by the experience.
From working with the computer,
and web, and graphic design.
I've learned how to do marketing
and get people in to message
me.
Buy one get one free,
and that kind of stuff.
I've always been really
creative and a self-starter.
The best one I ever
had, for this as least,
was the biggest penis contest.
Everybody was
sending me pictures.
Everybody.
Because all girls will
post don't send d pics.
Don't send them.
I don't want them.
So I was the girl that
said, you send them.
And the guys just love that.
Sometimes I do feel
a little bit and I
wish I wouldn't have
sold myself for so low
whenever I needed to
pay a bill that day.
But then I just think
this is step one
and I am gonna go
even further in life.
So I don't have to worry
about feeling cheap right now
because one day I'm not
going to feel cheap.
But money is everything so
I need money for everything.
The thing that I like the least
about it is sometimes the guys
are really mean and treat you
like you're a piece of meat.
But then I realize how much
the guys do get out of it.
And how much the
girls get out of it.
And it's completely
mutually beneficial.
The first thing in the
morning I get to see
is somebody saying, oh wow,
you're just so beautiful.
That's great.
It makes me feel good.
Whenever they realize that I'm
a person, that I have feelings.
That's what I like.
Be sure to check out
this next episode.
You can see the neon lights.
The 40 story tall casinos.
And then right beneath that is
this dark and grey world where
people are just
trying to survive.
Thanks for watching
Seeker Stories.
Please subscribe to see
new videos every week.